if we can't take that tangent briefly
with Dei diversity equity and inclusion
what is the good and what is the harm of
such programs d i I know people are a DI
Consultants or some the actually I have
a dear friend who I love very much um
who does Dei
absolutely decent people what they want
to do
is create bonds of understanding
friendship compassion among people
people who are different unfortunately
the research on what a lot of di
actually does is often has the opposite
of that and I think that it's partially
a problem with some of the ideology that
comes from uh critical race Theory which
is a real thing by the way um that that
informs a lot of Dei that actually makes
it something more likely to divide than
unite well we talk about this in
coddling the American mind as the
difference between common Humanity
identity politics and common enemy
identity politics and I think that I
know some of the people that I know who
who do Dai they really want it to be
common Humanity identity politics but
some of the actual ideological
assumptions that are baked in can
actually cause people to feel more
alienated from each other
now when I started at fire my first
cases involved 911.
um and it was bad uh professors were
getting targeted professors were losing
their jobs for saying insensitive things
about 911 and both from from the right
and the left actually in that case
actually sometimes more a lot more from
the right
um and it was really bad and about five
professors lost their jobs that's bad
five professors are over a relatively
short period of time being fired for a
political opinion that's something that
you know would get written up in any
previous decades
we're now evaluating like how many
professors have been uh targeted for
cancellation between 2014 and uh middle
of this year July of of 2023. we're at
about well well over a thousand attempts
to get professors uh fired or punished
usually driven by students and
administrators often driven by
professors unfortunately as well
about two-thirds of those result in the
professor being punished in some way
everything from you know having their
article removed to suspension Etc
about one-fifth of those result in
professors being fired so right now
we're it's it's almost 200 190 um
professors being fired
um so I want to give some context here
uh the the Red Scare is generally
considered to have been from 1947 to
1957. it ended by the way in 57 when it
finally became clear
um thanks to the first amendment that
you couldn't actually fire people for
their ideologies prior to that
a lot of universities thought they could
this guy is a very doc uh doctrinaire
communist uh you know they can't be just
waited I'm gonna fire them
um they thought they actually could do
that
um and it was only 57 when the law was
established so like right now these are
happening in an environment where
freedom of speech academic freedom are
clearly protected
um at public colleges in in the United
States and we're still seeing these kind
of numbers
um during during the the Red Scare the
biggest study that was done of what was
going on is I think this came out in
like 55 and the evaluation was that
there was about 62 professors fired for
for being communists and about 90
something professors fired for political
views overall
um that usually is it is reported as
being about 100.
um so 60 90 100 depending on how you
look at it I think the number is
actually higher
um but that's only because of hindsight
like what I mean by hindsight is we can
look back and we actually find there are
more professors who who were fired as
time reveals
we're at 190 professors fired and I
still have to put up with people saying
this isn't even happening and I'm like
in the nine and a half years of Castle
culture 190 professors fired in the 11
years of uh of the Red Scare
probably you know somewhere around 100
maybe probably more it's got the number
is going to keep going up um but unlike
during the Red Scare where people could
clearly tell something was happening the
craziest thing about cancer culture is
so I'm still dealing with people who are
saying this isn't happening at all and
it hasn't been subtle on campus and we
know that's a wild undercount by the way
because when we when we surveyed
professors
Seventeen percent of them said that they
had been threatened with uh threatened
with investigation or actually
investigated for what they taught said
or or their research and one-third of
them said that they were told by
administrators not to take on
controversial research so like
extrapolating that out that's a huge
number and the reason why you're not
going to hear about a lot of these cases
is because there are so many different
Conformity inducing mechanisms in the
whole thing yeah and that's one of the
reasons why the idea that you'd add
something like a d like requiring a Dei
statement to be hired or to get into a
school Under the current environment is
so completely nuts we have had a genuine
crisis of academic freedom over the last
you know particularly since 2017 on
campuses we have very low Viewpoint
diversity to begin with and under these
circumstances administrators to start
saying you know what the problem is we
have too much heterogeneous thought we
have we're not homogeneous enough we
actually need in we need another
political litmus test which is nuts and
that's what a Dei statement effectively
is because there's no way to actually
fill out a dais statement without
someone evaluating you on your politics
it's CR it's Crystal Clear we even did
an experiment on this uh Nate Honeycutt
he got something like almost like 3 000
professors to participate evaluating
different kinds of Dei statements
um and one was basically like the
standard kind of identity politics
intersectionality one one was about
Viewpoint diversity one was about
religious diversity and one was about
socioeconomic diversity as far as where
my heart really is it's that we have too
little socioeconomic diversity
particularly in Elite higher ed but also
in education period so we the experiment
was
large participation really interestingly
set up and it tried to model the way a
lot of these Dei policies were actually
implemented and one of the ways these
have been implemented and I think in
some of the California schools is that
administrators and go through the Dei
statements before
anyone else looks at them and then
eliminates people off the top depending
on how
they feel about their Dei statements and
the one on
um Viewpoint diversity I think like half
of the people who reviewed it would
eliminate it right out
um and I think it was basically the same
for religious diversity it was slightly
better like 40
um for socioeconomic diversity but that
kills me like the idea that kind of like
yeah that actually is the kind of
diversity that I think we need a great
deal more of in in higher education you
can agree with it's not hostile to the
other kinds by the way um but the idea
that we need more people from the bottom
you know of three quarters of American
society like in uh higher education I
think should be something we could all
get around that the only one that really
succeeded was the one that's that
sprouted back exactly the kind of you
know of ideology that that they thought
the readers would like which is like
okay
there's no way this couldn't be a
political litmus test we've proved that
it's a political litmus test and still
school after school it is adding these
to its application process to make
schools still more ideologically
homogenous why does that have a negative
effect is it because
it enforces a kind of group think where
people are afraid
start becoming afraid to sort of think
and speak
freely liberally about whatever but one
it selects for people who tend to be you
know farther to the left
um in a situation where you already have
uh people a situation where universities
do lean decidedly that way but it also
establishes essentially a set of sacred
ideas that if you're being quizzed on
whether or you know what you've done to
advance anti-racism
um inter uh uh how you've been conscious
of intersectionality it's unlikely that
you'd actually get in if you said by the
way I actually think these are dubious
Concepts I think they're thin I think
they're philosophically not very
defensible basically like if if your
position was I actually I actually
reject
um these Concepts as being over simple
um you're not you're not going to get in
and and I think that um the person that
I always think of that wasn't a
right-winger that would be like go to
hell if you if you made him fill one of
these things out it's fine man I feel
like if you get if you give one of these
things to Richard Feynman he'd be like
he would tear it to pieces
yeah then not get the job
[Music]
yeah there's some element of it that
creates this
hard to pin down fear so you said like
the firing the thing I wanted to say is
firing a hundred people or 200 people
the point is even firing one person I've
just seen it it can create this quiet
ripple effect of fear of course that
single firing of a fact oh absolutely
has a ripple effect across tens of
thousands of people of educators of of
uh who's hired what kind of
conversations are being had had what
kind of textbooks are chosen what kind
of sell censorship and different flavors
of that is happening it's hard to
measure that yeah I mean when you ask
professors about you know are they
intimidated under the current
environment
um the answer is yes and particularly
conservative professors you know already
you know reporting that they're you know
afraid for their jobs in a lot of
different cases you have a lot of good
statistics in the book things like
self-censorship when provided with the
definition of self-censorship at least a
quarter students that they self-censor
fairly often or very often during
conversations with other students with
professors and during classroom
discussions
25 27 and 28 respectively a quarter of
students also said that they are more
likely to self-center on campus now
at the time they were surveyed then they
were when they first started college so
sort of colleges kind of instilling this
idea of of censorship of self-censorship
and back to the Red Square comparison
and this is one of the interesting
things about the data as well is that
that same study that I was talking about
the most comprehensive study of the of
the Red Scare there was polling about
whether or not professors were
self-censoring due to the fear of the
environment and nine percent of
professors said that they were
self-censoring their research and what
they were saying
nine percent is really bad
um that's almost a tenth of professors
saying that they were actually their
speech was chilled when we did this
question for professors on our latest
faculty survey when you factored
together if they're we asked them are
they self-censoring in their research
are they self-centered in class are they
still censoring online Etc it was 90 of
professors so the the idea that we're
actually in an environment that is
historic um in terms of like how scared
people are actually of expressing
controversial views I think that it's
it's the reason why we're gonna actually
be studying this in 50 years the same
the the same way we study the Red Scare
um it's not the the idea that this isn't
happening is will just be correctly
viewed as insane